FRANK: We're heading to
a collector here in Georgia,
but we're running a little late.
FRANK: I'm figuring, you know,
he's a doctor, it's the South.
I mean, the flag says
on GPS we're right here.
MIKE: Dang, look at
the size of that building.
♪
MIKE: Hello.
FRANK: We made it.
MIKE: Here's a flyer of ours,
stuff that we buy.
We're sorry about being late.
CASEY: You can save it
and show the doctor.
He's been waiting.
MIKE: Okay.
FRANK: This is not
a good start to a pick.
MIKE: I feel like Frank and I
are back in high school,
going to the principal's office.
FRANK: Yeah, it's uncomfortable.
♪
FRANK: I can tell right away
this is not gonna be
a regular pick.
MIKE: Hello.
FRANK: How're you doing?
You Doc?
I'm Frank.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Nice to meet ya.
FRED: Fred.
FRED: My goal is
not to make money.
It's to collect specific things.
MIKE: Is this your building?
FRED: It is.
MIKE: Can we look
around a little bit?
FRED: Yeah.
MIKE: This guy is intense.
This is definitely not our
typical start to a pick.
MIKE: This place is massive!
FRANK: Wow.
MIKE: Dang.
How many square feet
you got up here?
FRED: I believe
it's about 8,000 total.
FRANK: Danielle said that
you did a lot of travelling,
buying overseas.
FRED: Yes.
MIKE: So your taste
is all over the board.
FRED: Yeah.
MIKE: 'Cause I'm looking around
here, you have textiles,
leather goods, some taxidermy.
FRED: I feel there's
a value in everything.
It's a curse and a blessing.
MIKE: Wow.
What's this?
"3rd Dimension Skims."
Oh, that's neat.
MIKE: So I see a skim board.
[claps]
Like, game on!
MIKE: So it's basically
like skateboarding.
I mean, you wait for
the tide to go out,
you got that thin
layer of water,
you chuck it across the sand,
and jump on there.
Look at that thing...
How old do you think that is?
FRED: I would say...
60s, 70s.
MIKE: Did you use this?
FRED: No, I found that
at the local flea market.
MIKE: With the graphics
and the colour
and the font, you know,
even with this splatter here,
it's interesting.
I mean, there's a little bit
of peeling with the veneer here,
but other than that, I mean...
FRANK: A little at the top.
MIKE: ...it's still cool
to hang on the wall.
FRED: Yeah.
MIKE: 50 bucks.
FRED: I'll do 75 on it.
MIKE: I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
I think it's
a great wall hanger.
I think there's a little room
on the back end of it.
MIKE: Doc and I are
both riding the same
wavelength into this thing.
FRANK: Hey, Fred!
FRED: What'd you find?
FRANK: The stained glass, it
looks like a matching pair here.
FRANK: I love stained glass.
It's an art form, you know?
So I look at these two,
they're tombstones,
they got great colour,
they're in nice shape,
and they're beautiful.
FRANK: Is this something
you would sell?
FRED: It is.
FRANK: Got a couple
pieces missing here.
Got a couple cracks
on this one.
What are you thinking?
FRED: I don't even remember
what I paid for them.
FRANK: My best would be like...
175 a piece, 350.
FRED: Alright, I'll do that.
FRANK: You'll do that?
Okay.
FRED: Alright.
FRANK: Good deal.
MIKE: The Doc showed us
a lot of unusual items,
items that you
don't normally see.
MIKE: I'm always gonna
remember The Fred Building.
FRED: Well...
MIKE: Thank you, buddy,
I appreciate you.
FRED: I appreciate y'all coming.
MIKE: Yeah.
FRED: You know, as a scientist
and having studied animals,
they were the kind of guys
that I'd like to hang out with.
[honks horn]
FRANK: See ya, Fred!
Take care!
FRED: We'll see ya, man.
♪